hey bash what we doing oh yeah you  excited Wiz Khalifa and amber roses son  Sebastian is the ultimate swifty he's a  fan  he loved tellus with amber and Wiz took  their five-year-old son backstage to  meet the reputation singer for the first  time and his reaction was priceless  this comes after Amber's followers  trolled her little boy when she posted a  video of Sebastian singing along to a  t-swift song amber told ET how it all  turned around for the better  shout out to Taylor Swift she sent him a  whole package like VIP tickets and  everything like that she's really  amazing she was a fan she did so I I  posted a video of him singing wicked and  I guess she's seen it and then she sends  it to you know my manager  people just have all these negative  things to say instead of just being like  this is the sweetest most amazing little  boy and he likes what he likes and he  has amazing parents that allow him to be  who he wants to be  [Music]